madam president of the commission of
the european union
ladies and gentlemen commissioners
mr vice-president of the senate in
charge of international affairs
ladies and gentlemen ladies and
gentlemen presidents of the senate commission a
man the vice-president I
am happy to see you again
madam president of the
european commission after our exchanges in
brussels it was last november 29
and to welcome you to the senate of the
republic in a this training
i was going to say a little solemn
you declared it in a world of your
visit  in paris and allow me to
quote you without france the european union
would not be what it has become
today
his remarks in fact oblige us, madam
president, because he
associates french ambition and european ambition
the  senate he will take his full part
you have in front of you madam the
president of the commission ladies and
gentlemen the commissioners in
addition to the first vice president l  he
presidents of the Senate committees,
which testifies to the crucial importance
given to our meeting,
I also see the
presence here of the college of European commissioners as
a sign of respect and friendship with regard
to our country
but also to  regard to all of
its institutional and
political components and particularly
the senate the senate mobilized very early on
to prepare the
parliamentary deadlines for the french presidency
of the european union
less publicized than the appointments
concerning the executive the role of the
national parliaments, as we mentioned
last night, madam president,
yes, the role of national parliaments
under an incumbent European
presidency is nonetheless
essential,
because parliamentarism and
democracy are at the heart of
European values ​​and parliaments
national governments have a natural vocation to
be as close as possible to citizens and
territories
because the control of subsidiarity l  he
transposition of European standards into
national law the ratification of
international and trade agreements
are an integral part of
parliamentary powers because the senate
fully exercises its role of
monitoring government activity in European song
and the senate will have a special role to
play in  during this presidency which
will be marked where you know
by important electoral deadlines in
france
the senate will be the assault only high
elected institution of the french republic not to
know elections during this
semester
it will therefore ensure without interruption a
complete presidency  over the entire
first six months of the year,
before giving the floor, Madam
President of the Committee, I
would like to mention the four major ones
at the time that will punctuate the
senatorial aspect of the French presidency
these major meetings will have one thing in
common they will all be  placed under the
sign of a
reaffirmed European sovereignty  rmed
parliamentary sovereignty in the first
place and the role of national parliaments
at European level it will be the
conference bringing together in the senate the
presidents of the European affairs committees
of all the
national parliaments it is next week and
13 and 14 January in  a format called
kozak to consider how we can
give more weight to this body
and strengthen its role this
is one of the objectives that we
have set ourselves this role is essential,
particularly in social sustainability
and the decision of European citizens
to the measures taken  i am thinking of the
climate dimension that we were discussing yesterday
with vice president
timerman sovereignty in terms of
foreign security and defense policy
secondly during the perez
and psdc conference which will take place on 24 and 25
february next
it will focus  on the keystone
European defense solidarity
as threats to the very
borders of the European Union  ean are
multiplying and that ambitions for
power instability is
unfortunately gaining ground everywhere the
representative joseph bourrel had
the opportunity to detail his issues during
the dinner last night offered by the
president of the republic
economic sovereignty
during the conference devoted  at
the strategic economic autonomy of
the european union will take place on march 13 and
14 we have all seen the
industrial flaws of the union at the beginning
and during the decaux vide pandemic and its
dependence on asia, in particular
the  European preference devices
presented by commissioners thierry
breton and vice-president vladis
dombrovskis in
order to remedy the shortages of
electronic chips or semiconductors which
has meant that our companies are so hard to
assume in this context a crucial influence on
the technological sovereignty
of the union  is at stake its digital sovereignty
because through the control of access to
data it is  both the protection
of privacy and the diversity of access
to markets that need to be strengthened in the
face of the digital giants it is the
heart of your gang to Madam Vice
President hashtag is
finally the sovereignty that results  of a
forced control of the external borders
with the conference relating to the
European union facing the migratory challenges
which will be held here on May 15 and 16
a sovereign union is above all a
union which decides who welcomes it on its
soil with respect  of course the
values ​​that drive it, but without
complacency or weakness in traveling
to greece and lithuania in December
have shown me and underlined to us
the importance of these subjects,
madam president of the
european commission,
ladies and gentlemen, should conclude by
quoting  so bad weather we celebrated
this morning the memory of the pantheon with
that of jean monnet she declared in
2011 when I look at these last 60
years
the european union is what  we have
done better of
course the european union can be improved
and simone veil was moreover the
first to recognize it but it is up to
all of us to make it
better it has advanced taking care
not to weaken what  others
built with so much perseverance
and applications she also liked to
repeat it was in an
electoral campaign in which i participated if i
love france i choose europe
this is the motto i wish to
remember  with all of you on the edge of this
summit is European in front of someone who
also campaigned with her, I include her
on the frontispiece of the
senatorial section of the French presidency
of the European union so that she will
be our compass again  welcome
here to the senate madam president a
soul and gentlemen commissioners
thank you very much sir president
sir ladies and gentlemen
vice presidents and members of the senate
you have sited me is sir
pre  sident you said that i am ten years old
france there is no europe and i
would like to add without
parliamentarians there is no
democracy and that is why thank you
very much for having us here
today  today to discuss the work
for european citizens
it was really
a form of warm reception that
we received here in france to celebrate the
beginning of the french presidency of the
council and yes it was
impressive summer at the pantheon see
the memorial of simone veil
simone veil bears witness to
the darkest hours of our
common history and a woman who symbolizes
reconciliation simone veil who was the
first woman to be president of
the european parliament
that is to say really monsters x and
the  democracy for all
and cement lifted who really fought
for women's rights in
impressive form so it was
very very touching for me to be here
today
this presidency comes at a time when
it is
extremely  t necessary because
we are living in exceptional times
we have the great crisis
of the pandemic
this fight against the pandemic is not
over but we also have a great
European success that is to say before
developing vaccines for
everyone  now the emirates the r
how do you say m n
you know it
and marnais minus the vaccines that we have
developed here in europe we have delivered
1.2 billion doses to europeans but
we have delivered this year exported is
given to the world
1,  5 billion doses of vaccines but
we not only have the
health crisis but we also have the
great climate crisis is there too
we have an answer it's the
green pact this answer there we have
our climate law but now we
have  the
detailed proposals on the table we
really count on you to move forward
cc field move these files forward
because now is the time to act to
really be able to give a  he
European response,
the first in the world with regard to
this
climate crisis the health crisis the climate crisis
all of this has had its impact on our
economy and still has its impact on
our economy but here too a
great European success we have
developed together  the
next generation you recovery plan 800 billion
rupees to invest in the green pact
and in digital
and of course we also have
tensions in our neighborhood I'm not going
to go into details but all that
shows that it's a time  exceptional
that we are experiencing at the moment and that is
why we are really happy
that we have a presidency with
such experience such political weight
and such wisdom to have the
presidency for the council at the moment
we are counting on this
French presidency but we are also important
to you, ladies and gentlemen of the senate,
senators, because the
French senate is indeed one of the
parliamentary chambers.  most active members thank you
very much for that in the
political dialogue with the European institutions
we greatly appreciate the opinions of the
initiatives that you have submitted to you
as well as your reactions to our
proposals and you, Mr.
President, you mentioned kozak
thank you also very much for your commitment
commitment with kozak
because it allows us to keep in touch
and really work together
during this presidency so we
are happy to be here and thank you
once again for having received us
so warmly
madam president if you don't mind
I will  give the floor to the
first vice-presidents of the senate then
our committee presidents will
give you all the themes on
which
he is working then
we will have a little time perhaps
so that, if you wish, under your
authority the commissioners intervene
in the lapse of time  time if you
agree president karoutchi